the ring the American remake of the
original Japanese film ring which I have
reviewed if you guys didn't see I did
review the original Japanese film in
preparation for the new rings film
coming out in October I'm excited to
talk about these movies I decided to
skip ring two I think that film is OK at
best it failed to present a compelling
reason to be a movie beyond the fact
that the first one was so successful I
decided to skip that movie as well as
all the pointless SATA ko spin-offs that
have happened so now let's talk about
the original the Ring remake that came
out in America in 2002 I saw this movie
in theaters when I was 14 years old and
it absolutely scared the shit out of me
it really did at the time I hadn't seen
the original Japanese movie and so all
of this was very new and very fresh to
me and sitting in that theater I felt
cold
I felt unsettled it absolutely creeped
into my skin and it affected me very
deeply as a 14-year old I was seeing the
ring face that people have the I was
seeing that face in Windows every time I
opened my closet every time I open my
locker at school I saw that damn face
this movie yeah got to me it's safe to
say it follows a very similar structure
as the Japanese film if you haven't seen
that film if you didn't see my review
this movie is about a cursed videotape
if you watch this tape you receive a
phone call and a voice tells you you
have seven days to live and our main
character played by Naomi Watts is a
reporter who's trying to figure out the
mystery of this tape and learn about how
she can hopefully survive along with her
ex-husband and son as I said it follows
a very similar structure to the Japanese
films certain scares are done in the
same way the famous I saw her face a lot
of those sequences are handled similarly
in this film but this one was directed
by Gore Verbinski and I think he did a
very good job at crafting a beautifully
shot film that was very well edited and
similar to the Japanese film had a quiet
unsettling sense of tragedy this entire
film is permeated with sadness there
isn't a moment in this film or the
original that felt as if it was happy
that there are very few moments where
characters sit back and go it's an
stay outside no it's even the
cinematography it's always very murky
there's an emphasis on blueish green
colors that are reflected very much so
in the cursed video which i think is one
of the things that is an improvement
over the Japanese film the cursed video
here I find far more frightening even
though the first one was very creepy I
do find that to be one of the elements
in this film that they improved upon
this is one of the better remakes out
there something else I feel they
improved on in this movie was the
protagonist in this movie her name is
Rachel I think that she's a more
well-rounded character I feel like she's
more of a person in the original film
she was kind of the audience character
we went on this journey with her her
husband was really the one who figured
out most of everything except for the
big reveal at the end and his character
explained so much to her through
exposition scenes in this film the lead
character played by Naomi Watts I find
much better and I think she did a really
great job in this movie that's
definitely for me one of the pluses of
this remake at the same time though by
boosting the character of Rachel the
husband character takes a dip in the
original film he was a clairvoyant he
could touch objects and get visions he
was a really compelling character and I
loved the actor who portrayed him I've
always loved him from Last Samurai The
Wolverine I think he's a fantastic actor
and I'm not going to try to butcher his
name but I love that actor in this film
the ex-husband character was far more
conventional he's your typical very
cynical character who doesn't believe in
anything supernatural and it takes
forever for him to take his ex-wife
seriously a lot less compelling than the
original but the son in this film was
definitely given more to do than yo ichi
was in the original that character was
basically just like hey can you go away
because we need to have a movie and your
little kids or can you just go away and
this film the son character was given a
lot more to do it's also a higher budget
and so things are going to look better
and sound better hans zimmer score is
really great the majority of the most
frightening and memorable parts of this
remake are paying homage to the original
so you kind of have to look at that
original and give it major props for
that
but the things they did differently
surprisingly actually really work a lot
of times when you change things too much
in remakes or when you're adapting
source material it doesn't always work
the back story they gave to the
character of Samarra in the
film was also very different and it was
a little bit less Eastern and definitely
more of a Western mentality story and it
worked for this film and it also gave it
another layer of tragedy there are more
supernatural things going on in this
movie though that the original hat even
though we had psychic characters in that
film and a curse videotape it was a
little bit more grounded and it felt a
little bit more realistic in this film
there are a few more supernatural
elements that aren't fully explained
that you don't fully understand but it's
nowhere near as bad as the ring to which
I'm going to talk about next
this film was unsettling it was very
creepy certain characters were given a
boost that weren't as compelling in the
original but certain characters also
took a dip overall this is one of the
better remakes Gore Verbinski did a very
good job directing this movie it looks
great it sounds great Naomi Watts was
excellent in this movie and I think it
actually was the first time that I had
ever seen her in a movie so that's
really cool I'm gonna give the ring of
B+ so guys stay tuned because very soon
I'm going to be reviewing the ring -
that's going to be fun also I thought
it'd be kind of cool to share with you
guys something from back in the day if
you never watched our scary movie
special we did a few years ago I
actually had you guys submit creepy
footage that we could use to make our
own cursed videotape in tribute to the
ring because every year my wife and I do
a scary Halloween special around October
and we're going to do it again this year
I'm excited for that but a couple years
ago we did this video and you guys
submitted some really creepy ass footage
and I thought it'd be fun just since I'm
talking about the ring again to share
that footage with you guys again for any
my newer subscribers who never saw that
video back in the day so here's that
video from a couple years back as always
thank you so much for watching it if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
is it
you
[Music]
[Applause]